ich darf Sie recht herzlich begrüßen zur
heutigen Pressekonferenz mit dem Herrn
Bundeskanzler Karl nehammer der
Verteidigungsministerin Claudia Danner
und dem Finanzminister
der Bundeskanzler ich würde sehr suchen
um ihre Worte
meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren
einen guten Morgen
es ist nicht nur ein guter Morgen für
uns alle gemeinsam heute sondern ein
besonders guter Morgen für die
österreichische Landesverteidigung
seit Jahrzehnten kämpfen wir
vor allem die Verteidigungsminister in
unterschiedlicher Einsatzbereitschaft
vor allem aber die Soldatinnen und
Soldaten
für ein höheres Verteidigungsbudget
das dramatische ist dass wir jetzt in
Zeiten des Krieges Leben und schon
davor erkannt haben und auch ein breiter
gesellschaftlicher Konsens stattgefunden
hat dass militärische Landesverteidigung
ein wichtiges Kernelement der
Sicherheitspolitik ist
österreichische Bundesheer mit seinen
Soldatinnen und Soldaten hat einen
wesentlichen Beitrag geleistet in der
pandemiebekämpfung in der Unterstützung
der kritischen Infrastruktur und war
nicht mehr wegzudenken
von Beginn weg ihrer ministerinnenschaft
hat sich die Verteidigungsministerin
für ein höheres Verteidigungsbudget
eingesetzt nicht damit
ein Selbstzweck erfüllt wird sondern
damit die Sicherheit dieses Landes
gestärkt wird
die Dramatik des Krieges seit 70 Jahren
herrscht wieder Krieg in Europa
hat vor Augen geführt dass all das was
vermeintliche und
andere ExpertInnen Experten vorhergesagt
haben dass es keine starke militärische
Landesverteidigung mehr braucht sich als
falsch erwiesen hat
Politik ist dazu da Entscheidungen zu
treffen und daraus die notwendigen
Ableitungen das haben wir getan
gemeinsam
mit dem Koalitionspartner in der
Hinsicht dass wir das
Verteidigungsbudget in den nächsten vier
Jahren um 5,3 Milliarden Euro erhöhen
werden
das sind notwendige Investitionen in die
militärische Infrastruktur das bedeutet
dass Kasernen
autark werden in der
selbstversorgungsfähigkeit aber auch für
andere da sind wenn es darum geht
Versorgungssicherheit zu leisten im Fall
eines Blackouts oder anderer
Katastrophenszenarien
das heißt dass unsere Soldatinnen und
Soldaten in der Schutzausrüstung
der Zeit entsprechend ausgestattet
werden um ihre Einsätze bestmöglich im
Inland wie im Ausland erfüllen zu können
und das heißt auch dass wir die
Mobilität
das österreichischen Bundesheeres in der
Luft und am Lande deutlich stärken und
verbessern werden damit das was in der
Verfassung in der umfassenden
Landesverteidigung festgeschrieben ist
nämlich die militärische Sicherheit auch
tatsächlich geleistet werden kann
noch ein Wort zu umfassenden
Landesverteidigung ein Begriff der jetzt
die letzten Jahre in Vergessenheit
geraten ist
der nicht mehr beachtet worden ist
und heute mehr denn je wird sichtbar
das militärische Landesverteidigung das
Gebot der Stunde ist gerade in Zeiten
des Krieges in Europa
die militärische Sicherheit wird jetzt
weiter ausgebaut es braucht aber auch
eine Widerstandsfähigkeit und eine
Haltung innerhalb einer demokratischen
Gesellschaft um Kriegspropaganda
abzuwehren und da macht klar zu machen
das Demokratie unser höchstes Gut ist
und wir alles dafür tun werden um die
Demokratie zu verteidigen und wir haben
auch gesehen dass wirtschaftliche
Verteidigungsbereitschaft ein Gebot der
Stunde sein wird das hat Österreich
wahrgenommen indem es zum ersten Mal in
der Geschichte der Zweiten Republik
neben einer strategischen Ölreserve auch
eine strategische gasreserve in der Höhe
von 20 Terawattstunden Milliarden von
Kubikmeter Gas angelegt hat um diese
Versorgungssicherheit zu gewährleisten
aber mit dem Fragestellungen und
Herausforderungen die wirtschaftliche
Landesverteidigung betreffend sind wir
noch lange nicht fertig
Abhängigkeiten
lieferkettenausfälle all das sind
Bedrohungsszenarien die neben der
militärischen Bedrohung auch in den
letzten Monaten sichtbar geworden sind
das heißt es gibt viel zu tun
ich bin froh die Landesverteidigung in
den Händen der Bundesministerin zu
wissen und Herr Finanzminister die
persönlich sage ich ein großes Danke ich
bin jetzt seit 30 Jahren Soldat seit
mehr als 28 Jahren setze ich mich als
informationsoffizier dafür ein dass das
Verteidigungsbudget erhöht wird und eine
Bereitschaft in der politischen
Auseinandersetzung dafür gefunden wird
und jeder Finanzminister noch war immer
wieder verführt zu sagen aber in die
militärische Landesverteidigung nach so
viel muss nicht sein
du hast
aufgehört mit dieser Politik ich weiß
dass das in Zeiten wie diesen besonders
herausfordernd ist zu dir kommen derzeit
gerade alle um brauchen Geld im wahrsten
Sinne des Wortes ich bin froh Dich als
Finanzminister zu haben der hier die
finanziellen Ressourcen zur Verfügung
stellt um die militärische
Landesverteidigung Zukunft zu machen
sehr geehrter Herr Bundeskanzler sehr
geehrter Herr Finanzminister sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren
der 24 februar und die folgenden Wochen
und Monate haben auf unglaublich
tragische Weise veranschaulicht dass der
Krieg
auf europäischen Boden zu einer Realität
geworden ist
wir erleben aber gerade in den letzten
Jahren dass sich die Sicherheitslage so
wie unsere Expertinnen und Experten das
auch immer wieder in der
sicherheitspolitischen Jahresvorschau
festgehalten haben massiv verschlechtert
hat und schon angesprochen die Vielzahl
von Krisen beginnen von der
corona-pandemie über die Energiekrise
aber auch die sozialen Herausforderungen
durch die Inflation sind dazu gekommen
all diese Krisen sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren haben etwas gemeinsam für das wir
stets weiterkämpfen müssen
nämlich den Schutz unseres Landes der an
erster Stelle stehen muss und wie können
wir den Schutz unseres Landes besser
verteidigen und aufrechterhalten als mit
einem modernen und gut ausgestatteten
österreichischen Bundesheer und das ist
nur möglich mit einem höheren Budget
dieses höhere Budget ist von allen
Parteien aus der Streit gestellt worden
es hat also immer ein dahingehendes
Einvernehmen gegeben auch mit unserem
Koalitionspartner
und wenn ich hier mit dem Bundeskanzler
mit dem Finanzminister stehen darf dann
ein ganz großes Dankeschön
an dich Herr Bundeskanzler ein großes
Dankeschön an Dich ja Finanzminister
wenn wir gemeinsam diesen großen
Verhandlungserfolg heute verkünden
dürfen 16 Milliarden Euro
Verteidigungsbudget in den kommenden
vier Jahren das ist eine Grundlage die
uns Planbarkeit ermöglicht die uns auch
eine klare Entwicklung unserer
Fähigkeiten ermöglicht nach einer
finanziellen Durststrecke über Jahre
oder besser gesagt über Jahrzehnte
mit diesem
Verteidigungsbudget können wir viele
Investitionen tätigen die auf der
Strecke geblieben sind ich glaube aber
gerade in Zeiten wie diesen ist es auch
wichtig
den Steuerzahlerinnen und Steuerzahlern
eines zu versichern wir werden nichts
kaufen was wir nicht unbedingt und
dringend brauchen wir gehen nach einem
konkreten Investitionsplan vor der den
Kriterien des bundeshaushaltsrechts und
der Verwaltung entspricht das heißt
vieles davon wird nicht von heute auf
morgen gehen insbesondere wenn es um die
Baumaßnahmen geht und Beschaffungen geht
die natürlich auch Zeit verlangen es ist
ein Zeitplan den wir uns gesetzt haben
der ein enger ist den wir aber schaffen
werden zu den konkreten
investitionsschwerpunkten
die beginnen bei der Autarkie wie vom
Bundeskanzler schon angesprochen zur
Stärkung der
Verteidigungsfähigkeit gegenüber die
Mobilität der Einsatzkräfte bis zum
Bereich Schutz der Soldatinnen und
Soldaten das heißt moderne Ausrüstung
Waffen und Gerät im Bereich der
Mobilität der Einsatzkräfte werden wir
den Schwerpunkt auf geschützte Mobilität
legen in Ergänzung zu den geschützten
Fahrzeugflotten die wir bereits haben
brauchen wir dringend Transportfahrzeuge
ein gutes Beispiel ist hier der
Radpanzer Bandur der auch aus
österreichischer Produktion stammt
weiters schnelle hochbewegliche
Fahrzeuge für unsere
Spezialeinsatzkräfte und Infanteristen
und geschützte Pionier und
sanitätsfahrzeuge auch in der Luft
müssen wir unsere transportfähigkeiten
ausbauen und verbessern wir haben einen
ersten Schritt ja schon gesetzt im
Bereich der Hubschrauber Flotte mit 18.9
Hubschraubern im Bereich der
Luftstreitkräfte werden wir unsere
Transportflugzeuge Herkules ab dem Jahr
2029 ersetzen und im Bereich der aktiven
luftraum-überwachung ist es notwendig
dass wir unsere Eurofighter aufrüsten
sie wissen dass viele der Fähigkeiten
die dringend notwendig sind nämlich
insbesondere in der Nacht detektieren zu
können nicht vorhanden ist das ist ja
bekannt auch das ist entsprechend
auszurüsten was die Schutz den Schutz
und die Wirkung unserer Soldatinnen und
Soldaten anbelangt brauchen wir moderne
Ausrüstung
individualschutzmitteln für Nachtkampf
und Kommunikation es wird in den
Kernbereich der militärischen
Landesverteidigung
investiert in den Schutz von Bedrohungen
aus der Luft das heißt wir werden neue
Fähigkeiten schaffen die so im
österreichischen Bundesheer noch nicht
gegeben hat es ist auch notwendig die
mechanisierte Truppe mit Kampfpanzern
Schützenpanzern pionierpanzern der
Artillerie zu modernisieren um damit
Panzerschutz Feuerkraft und hohe
Beweglichkeit auch sicher zu stellen der
Bauplan für die Kasernen
Autarkie begonnen im Jahr 2021 bereits
wird bis zum Jahr 2025
vollendet sein was brauchen wir in den
attacken-kasernen wir brauchen
ausreichend Versorgungsgüter wir
brauchen eine hochwertige
Sanitätsversorgung wir brauchen
Energieunabhängigkeit wo wir jetzt schon
sehr vieles auch selbst erzeugen an
Energie wir werden im Jahr 2023 mit
Beginn des nächsten Jahres die ersten
beiden Kasernen fertiggestellt haben
sehr geehrte Damen und Herren auch der
Kampf im cyberraum und die elektronische
Kampfführung sind heute auf dem
Gefechtsfeld nicht mehr wegzudenken das
heißt auch in diesem Bereich müssen wir
investieren digitale
führungskommunikationsmittel die bilden
die Voraussetzung für ein modernes
Bundesheer ja und
Übungen die jetzt Gott sei Dank wieder
regelmäßig auch stattfinden können
erfordern auch dass wir die nötigen
Mittel für alle Teile des Bundesheeres
sicherstellen das heißt für die
Soldatinnen und Soldaten des aktiv und
des Miliz Standes all diese
Notwendigkeiten sind in meinem Haus
intensiv ausgearbeitet worden bauen auf
auf einem adaptierten risikobild nach
Beginn des Angriffskrieges Putins auf
die Ukraine es freut mich wirklich sehr
dass wir gemeinsam das Verhandlungsziel
erreicht haben unser
landesverteidigungsbudget schon im
kommenden Jahr am 680 Millionen Euro
aufstocken werden das sind 20 Prozent
mehr als das vergangene Jahr und wie
eingangs schon angesprochen insgesamt in
den kommenden vier Jahren 16 Milliarden
Euro
es ist mir wichtig auch eines
aufzuklären die mediale
Berichterstattung wo nach die Pensionen
aus der Untergruppe 14 militärische
Angelegenheiten finanziert werden ist
schlichtweg falsch fakt ist dass wir
den Trend der Steigerung des
bruttoinlands Produktes bis 2030 32
fortsetzen und das Ziel nämlich 1,5% des
BIP sicherzustellen bereits ab 2027
erreichen nicht zum Selbstzweck so wie
es der Herr Bundeskanzler schon
angesprochen hat sondern für die
Sicherheit Österreichs und für ein
modernes Bundesheer zudem werden wir ein
landesverteidigungsfinanzierungsgesetz
schaffen das zeitlich über den
bundesfinanzrahmen hinausgeht und uns
damit über zehn Jahre Planbarkeit und
finanzierungsperspektive gibt sie wissen
der Aufbau und die Entwicklung von
militärischen Fähigkeiten ist komplex
das benötigt Zeit das benötigt auch
langfristige
Planungssicherheit und ich gehe davon
aus dass dann im Parlament dann auch
entsprechende Beschluss erfolgen wird
mit einem höchstmöglichen Grad auch an
Transparenz wie wir diese Mittel
verwenden werden das heißt es wird einen
landesverteidigungsbericht dann geben
der jeweils die sicherheitspolitischen
Rahmenbedingungen erklärt und beschreibt
die erforderlichere Reaktion und
Strategie aber auch die
fähigkeitsentwicklung ich freue mich
sehr dass wir damals erstmals in der
Geschichte tatsächlich auch legistische
Grundlagen schaffen die über den
Zeitraum der Legislaturperiode
hinausgehen und tatsächlich dann eine
Sicherstellung auch über zehn Jahre
schaffen können das ist enorm groß
Erfolg sehr geehrte Damen und Herren für
das österreichische Bundesheer nein für
die Sicherheit unseres Landes und dieser
Stelle noch einmal ein Dankeschön an den
Herrn Bundeskanzler und an den
Finanzminister bitte
ja vielen Dank sehr geehrte Damen und
Herren Bundeskanzler Frau
Bundesministerin
wenn sich die die Sicherheitslage in
Europa verändert dann müssen wir auch
mehr in die Sicherheit investieren das
ist glaube ich klar und wir investieren
ja wir investieren sehr viel Geld in die
Landesverteidigung in die Sicherheit
nächste Woche werden wir das Budget
vorstellen gesamthaft vorstellen und ich
kann Ihnen jetzt schon sagen neben der
Krisenbewältigung die uns natürlich
massiv fordert wird zwei Schwerpunkte
geben und eines davon ist natürlich die
Sicherheit das ist glaube ich gerade in
Zeiten wie diesen ganz entscheidend und
wir wollen mit diesem Budget
insbesondere wenn es um die Sicherheit
geht um die Landesverteidigung geht
nicht nur kurzfristig antworten geben
nicht nur kurzfristig notwendige
Antworten ergeben auf die
Herausforderungen die wir in dieser
nicht einfachen Zeit haben sondern wir
wollen gezielt den Bereiche investieren
die Österreich auch für die Zukunft
stärker machen und dazu gehört
selbstverständlich die
Landesverteidigung
jetzt setzt man sich natürlich mit
budgetherhöhungen immer Ziele auch und
die Frauen der Bundesministerin hat das
auch angesprochen ziel dieser
budgetherhöhung im Bereich der
Landesverteidigung ist es ein
leistungsfähiges ein fortschrittliches
Bundesheer auch weiterentwickeln zu
können ein Bundesheer das seine Aufgaben
erfüllen kann weil es eben dann auch
ausreichend finanziell ausgestattet ist
vor ein paar Jahren war die die
Ausrichtung eine andere die Ausrichtung
des Bundesheeres und die die Ausstattung
des Bundesheeres eine eine andere weil
natürlich unter anderem auch die
Sicherheitslage in Europa eine andere
war aber mit dem russischen
Angriffskrieg in Europa ist sind wir
alle in unserem Umfeld ist alles etwas
unsicherer geworden und deswegen müssen
wir auch wieder mehr investieren und das
tun wir mit diesem Budget das Ziel ist
es dass wir erstmals in der Geschichte
2027 auf 1,5% unseres
Bruttoinlandsprodukts
Landesverteidigung nur zum Vergleich die
neutrale Schweiz gibt circa ein Prozent
des Pieps für Landesverteidigung für
Militär aus wir investieren bis 2026
zusätzlich 5,3 Milliarden Euro in das
österreichische Bundesheer das ist so
viel wie noch nie im Vergleich zu 2022
steigt 2023 das Budget um 680 Millionen
Euro und ja die Frau Bundesministerin
hat es schon angesprochen weil es medial
in der Diskussion war ja man inkludiert
selbstverständlich in die Berechnung der
Militärausgaben immer auch die Pensionen
für Militärangehörige und das ist keine
Erfindung von uns sondern das ist eine
Definition der Militärausgaben der NATO
beispielsweise es gibt auch das
Stockholm international peace research
institutes auch diese
Berechnungsmethoden macht oder auch die
Weltbank macht genau diese
Berechnungsmethoden das ist so
vorgesehen weil man dadurch auch eine
internationale Vergleichbarkeit schafft
also es handelt sich im Vergleich zu den
vergangenen Jahren um die bisher sicher
größte und über die Jahre und das ist
auch wichtig über die Jahre
konstanteste Budget Aufstockung des
Bundesheers und wir ermöglichen durch
diesen stetig steigenden Budgetpfad
größere und auch langfristige
beschaffungsprojekte wir steigern
erstmals beispielsweise das Budget für
Investitionen 2023 auf über 20 Prozent
des Gesamtbudgets das ist auch erstmalig
so und der Personalaufwand der Anteil
des Personalaufwands sinkt am erstmals
auf 45% ab und damit kann verstärkt in
die Ausrüstung und in die Fähigkeit des
Bundesheeres investiert werden sehr
geehrte Damen und Herren als
Finanzminister ist mir natürlich der
sinnvolle Einsatz von Steuergeld das
wichtigste Anliegen und mit der
Investition in den Schutz unserer
Demokratie in den Schutz
von uns allen unserer Bürger in die
Sicherheit unserer Bürger und in unsere
Infrastruktur kommen wir diesem Anliegen
nach vielen Dank
danke sehr sehr geehrte Damen und Herren
ich darf um Fragen ersuchen
militärisch ich gehe von links nach
rechts
danke
Tour eine Frage an die Frau Ministerin
und den Herrn Bundeskanzler die haben
jetzt Monate lang den Bundesheer ein
Prozent versprochen
680 Millionen sind die Hälfte von einem
Prozent ungefähr wo ist die andere
Hälfte geblieben
vielleicht noch einmal zur
Berechnungsmethode
wenn es um das
Verteidigungsbudget geht und man
internationale Vergleichbarkeit doch
herstellen will spricht man eben auch
die Pensionen mit an was aber nicht
bedeutet dass diese aus der ug14 das
heißt dass unsere Budget bezahlt werden
das wäre ja gesetzlich gar nicht möglich
sondern die Bezahlung erfolgt über das
Sozialministerium über die ug 23 das was
wir versprochen haben ist und wir sind
früher am Ziel angelangt ab dem Jahr
2027 einen Prozentsatz von
1,5% des BIP
die absolute Zahlen noch einmal 16
Milliarden Euro in den nächsten vier
Jahren das heißt das Ziel wird früher
erreicht als das was wir unser zu Beginn
der Verhandlungen vorgenommen haben
also was ist immer das Wesentliche
ist aus meiner Sicht
die Aufgabe der Politik heraus zu
destillieren und daraus Ableitungen zu
definieren und dann Entscheidungen zu
treffen
das Wesentliche war dass wir
festgestellt haben dass das Bundesheer
über Jahre fast Jahrzehnte ausgehungert
worden ist
unterbudgetiert war und es eine wirklich
herausragende Leistung der Soldatinnen
und Soldaten ist die heute noch ihren
dienstversehen auch als
berufssoldatinnen und Berufssoldaten
solange durchgehalten zu haben wenn sie
sich oft von der Politik im Stich
gelassen gefühlt haben
das ist jetzt beendet
wir haben versprochen dass es mehr
Verteidigungsbudget geben wird wir haben
es gehalten
es ist faktisch 5,3 Milliarden Euro mehr
sind Fakten keine Vision kein Ausblick
keine Geschichte die erzählt wird
sondern faktisch dieses Geld muss
dringend in die militärische
Landesverteidigung investiert werden wie
auch immer sich jetzt
in einer Form der Orchideen
Auseinandersetzung mit dem Thema
was auch immer wohin eingerechnet wird
auseinandersetzen mag den wünsche ich
dabei viel Freude
entscheidend ist
5,3 Milliarden Euro mehr für die
militärische Sicherheit unserer Republik
und darauf kommt es an das haben wir
versprochen und das haben wir gehalten
als Ergänzung ganz kurz wir werden
nächstes Jahr 2023 dieses eine Prozent
des BIPs erreichen und zwar in aller
internationaler Vergleichbarkeit
die Idee die langfristige Finanzierung
in den Verfassungsrang zu schreiben habe
ich das richtig verstanden dass das
zugunsten dieses neuen
finanzierungsgesetzes dieses
zehnjährigen
gestorben ist
nein das Gegenteil ist der Fall aber
dieses
landesverteidigungsgesetz
finanzierungsgesetz muss ja beschlossen
werden noch im Parlament nachdem
Einigkeit darüber besteht dass eine
Planbarkeit über einen Zeitraum über das
Bundesfinanzrahmengesetz hinaus bestehen
soll gehe ich davon aus bzw hoffe ich
dass nicht nur der Koalitionspartner
dabei ist sondern sich dem auch andere
Parteien mit anschließen das Wichtige
ist dass wir damit tatsächlich über die
Legislaturperiode hinaus einen Pfad
schaffen das nicht mehr möglich macht so
wie in der Vergangenheit an erster
Stelle beim Verteidigungsbudget
einzusparen
darf ich kurz auf eine Zeitreise
mitnehmen erinnern Sie sich zurück 24.2
Kriegsausbruch es gab in der Folge
nationale sicherheitsräte und einer
davon war ein ganz wichtiges Signal
auch gegen die Angst gegen den Krieg
es gab eine Einstimmigkeit im Nationalen
Sicherheitsrat aller im
parlamentvertretern ein Parteien dass
das Verteidigungsbudget angehoben werden
muss die Umsetzung dieses Beschlusses
ist de facto jetzt durch die
Bundesregierung erfolgt jetzt beginnt
der parlamentarische Prozess ich gehe
davon aus dass gerade jetzt auch die
Oppositionsparteien die Chance nutzen
werden gemeinsam mit der Bundesregierung
für die mit dem militärische
Landesverteidigung ein Zeichen der
Geschlossenheit
der Einheit und vor allem auch dass
Sichtbarkeit der Wehrhaftigkeit unserer
Demokratie zu setzen und das Gesetz
mitzubeschließen
klar zu stellen das heißt sie streben
das als Verfassungsgesetz an dieses
verteidigungssicherungsgesetz und die
zweite Frage Herr Bundeskanzler sie
sprechen von architen ich brauche
trotzdem Namen auch wie viel in
Milliarden Euro oder Millionen Euro gibt
es heuer für Bundesheer wie viel für
Pensionen und wie viel ist es dann
nächstes Jahr nehmen wir wirklich die
konkreten Zahlen damit man es gut
vergleichen kann also die konkreten
Zahlen das ist ja mein Privileg in
seiner Pressekonferenz heute den
Finanzminister und meiner Seite der wird
sie dann nennen sind ja auch schriftlich
vorliegend ich bin erstaunlich dass 5,3
Milliarden Euro offensichtlich zu wenig
sind wenn man sagt dass sie mehr sind
ich halte das wie die wichtigste
Nachricht vor allem für die Soldatinnen
und Soldaten und das andere was Sie
gesagt haben nochmals sie sind ein
erfahrener innenpolitikjournalist mein
Ziel ist es und das haben wir erreicht
mehr Geld für das Bundesheer
sicherzustellen im Nationalen
Sicherheitsrat wurde einstimmig
beschlossen dass es mehr Budget für das
österreichische Bundesheer braucht ich
gehe davon aus dass die
Oppositionsparteien die Chance der
Geschlossenheit aus dem Nationalen
Sicherheitsrat nutzen werden um auch im
Parlament Geschlossenheit zu zeigen
Herr Finanzminister es geht noch um
Details die kann ich Ihnen dann gern
liefern aber nochmal zum zum prinzipiell
es hat sich nichts geändert in der
Darstellung und diese Steigerungen die
5,3 Milliarden wurden erwähnt dass
Prozent des BIP nächstes Jahr die 1,33
Prozent des BIP bis ins Jahr 2026 und
die 1,5 Prozent des BIP bis ins Jahr
2027 die angesprochen worden sind die
sind im internationalen Vergleich so wie
sie sind und auch mit der Vergangenheit
so wie sie sind da hat sich nichts
geändert jetzt kann man einmal hergehen
in einem Jahr und die Pensionen
rausrechnen und dann wieder rein rechnen
das bringt aber nichts sondern wir haben
die Vergleichbarkeit zur Vergangenheit
innerhalb Österreichs und die
internationale Vergleichbarkeit so wird
es einfach gemacht das ist der Standard
der internationale und diesen Vergleich
nehmen wir hier
Frau Ministerin sie haben auch die
Luftabwehr angesprochen und die
Nachrüstung der Eurofighter können Sie
das nochmal im Detail ausführen und ist
auch geplanten neue Eurofighter zu
kaufen drei Doppelsitzer aus Deutschland
sind da kolportiert worden und eine
zweite Frage auch über verpflichtende
Miliz Übungen wieder schon länger
diskutiert gibt es in der Frage schon
eine Entscheidung
was an erster Stelle notwendig ist bei
unseren Eurofightern ist die
Wiederherstellung der
detektionsfähigkeiten in der Nacht das
ist der erste Schritt der jetzt gesetzt
werden muss und selbstverständlich haben
wir in den verschiedensten Bereichen
jetzt auch zu schauen in welchen Staaten
Beschaffungsvorhaben stattfinden das
heißt wir werden natürlich schauen wo
können wir uns auch anschließen sie
wissen auf der anderen Seite auch dass
es strenge
vorgabenbeschaffungsbereich gibt
Priorität 1 ist jetzt einmal dass wir im
Bereich der Eurofighter diese
detektionsfähigkeit herstellen wenn sie
sie haben alle einen Stick mitbekommen
wo unser Generalmajor Hofbauer sehr
genau auch erklärt in welchen einzelnen
Bereichen wir auch neue Fähigkeiten
erwerben vielleicht werfen Sie da auch
dann noch einmal einen einen Blick
hinein
und die zweite Frage
geübt muss mehr werden das steht außer
Frage nicht zuletzt durch die Pandemie
waren wir stark daran gehindert wir
haben jetzt wieder sehr viele große
Übungen auch durchführen können wenn sie
an die Übungen Eisenerz denken oder an
die Übung Handwerk gehen einsteigt auch
denken ich glaube man muss zwei Dinge
unterscheiden wir müssen jede
Möglichkeit nutzen das wieder mehr geübt
und trainiert wird aber zum jetzigen
Zeitpunkt eine Verlängerung des
grundwertdienstes von 6 auf 8 Monate was
dieses angesprochene Modell der
verpflichtenden Miliz Übungen ja
bedeuten würde das sehe ich nicht
nachdem es keine weiteren Fragen gibt
darf ich mich recht herzlich bedanken
bitte
ich eile
hier noch eine Frage
[Musik]
sie haben jetzt alle drei auf den
Ukraine Krieg angespielt und dass das
jetzt ein besonderes das quasi
angesichts dieses Kriegs das besonders
wichtig sei
Österreich ist ein neutrales Land und
selbst wie das beste her der Welt hätten
würde das nichts und aktuellen Situation
in der Ukraine ändern was genau hat
Ukraine krieg jetzt mit der
budgetaufstockung des Bundesheers zu tun
wenn wir ja ich nehme an in diesem Plan
hat sich nichts geändert in keiner Weise
in diesem Krieg direkt eingreifen werden
also was hat das mit der Ukraine
wirklich zu tun
also auch hier
seit 70 Jahren gibt es wieder Krieg in
Europa das ist schon erstaunlich und das
ist kein österreichischer Feststellung
sondern das hat die gesamte Welt
erschüttert
und wenn Sie darüber nachdenken dass am
24.2 aus dem versionskrieg der
Russischen Föderation in der Ukraine
ausgebrochen ist in der Folge des
Krieges der Krieg bis an 500 km
Entfernung an die österreichische Grenze
herangekommen ist dass wir unmittelbar
betroffen sind von den
Flüchtlingsströmen von der Energiekrise
die er ausgelöst hat so hat der Krieg
dramatische Auswirkungen auf Europa und
im Wahrheit auch auf die Welt
der Krieger dazu geführt dass
bündnisfreie Staaten wie Finnland und
Schweden der NATO beigetreten sind
der deutsche Bundeskanzler spricht von
einer Zeitenwende und die Bundesrepublik
Deutschland wird 100 Milliarden Euro in
die deutsche Bundeswehr investieren und
es wird die größte Armee auf
europäischen Boden sein und das mit
Zustimmung der europäischen Partner
Österreich ist ein neutrales Land das
haben sie vorher schon erwähnt
und die Neutralität verpflichtet uns
auch in der Lage zu sein
selbstverteidigungsfähigkeiten zu haben
und sie so zu erhalten dass sie
tatsächlich auch Anwendung finden können
wenn es den notwendig ist
das ist der Grund warum wir alle auf den
Krieg replizieren weil der Krieg gezeigt
hat
dass es notwendig ist die militärische
Landesverteidigung wieder in den
Mittelpunkt der Politik zu stellen sich
mit ihr auseinanderzusetzen die
Fähigkeiten zu überprüfen und dort wo es
Schwächen gibt diese auszumärzte und
daraus Stärken zu entwickeln
Krisen zeigen immer
meistens in einer unglaublichen Härte
auf wo Schwachpunkte liegen und davon
ist Österreich nicht alleine betroffen
denken Sie daran dass es keinen
amerikanischen Präsidenten gegeben hat
in den letzten Jahren der nicht wenn
Europa besucht hat die NATO-Staaten
ermahnt hat ihre Verteidigungsbudgets zu
erhöhen das tun die jetzt alle auch
und weil wir eben nicht Mitglieder eines
Militärbündnisses sind müssen wir
besonders darauf achten dass unsere
militärische
Selbstverteidigungsfähigkeit entwickelt
ausgebaut und vor allem verstärkt wird
und der Krieg noch mal zurückkommen auf
ihre Frage der Krieg hat sichtbar
gemacht wie notwendig das ist
ja Bischof von der Wiener Zeitung eine
Frage wird es da auch eine neue
sicherheitsdokteen Creme jetzt im Rahmen
dieser aufrüstungsdebatte also die
letzte stammt ja aus 2013 und was ist
generell das militärische analytische
Rückgrat des Bundesheeres für die
kommenden Jahre
der 24 Februar hat eines notwendig
gemacht sich beginne jetzt mit dem
zweiten Teil der Frage nämlich dass wir
unser risikobild adaptieren und dass wir
ein streitkräfteprofil auf den neuen
auch Stand bringen und darauf aufbauend
werden eben auch die Investitionen
getätigt ich darf da noch einmal
verweisen auf den zur Verfügung
gestellten Stick wo das auch alles noch
einmal genau erklärt und verdeutlicht
wird von generalmayrhofbauer
was war der erste Teil der Frage
Sicherheits Doktrin ist im Parlament
erarbeitet worden das steht außer Frage
unabhängig davon ob sich die politischen
Parteien dazu entscheiden dieses zu tun
oder zu überarbeiten ist die Grundlage
jedenfalls mit dem heutigen Tag auch
sichergestellt nämlich dass wir mit
einem gut ausgestatteten Budget der gut
ausgestatteten österreichischen
Bundesheer die verfassungsrechtlichen
Aufgaben auch tatsächlich erfüllen
können
eine abschließende Frage also ich würde
gern zu den Zahlen zurückkommen noch
einmal also Frau Minister Herr
Bundeskanzler sie haben jetzt monatelang
ein Prozent des BIP versprochen ein
Prozent mindestens jetzt gibt es ein
Prozentrechnen sie die Pensionen dazu
und sagen da habt es ein Prozent also
ich habe gestern mit sehr viel
Offizieren gesprochen und ich muss Ihnen
sagen dass eigentlich Fassungslosigkeit
und Enttäuschung herrscht dass das
Bundesheer wieder mal mit weniger
abgespeist wird als versprochen wurde
also vielleicht darf ich darf ich es
noch einmal wiederholen weil die Zahl
glaube ich auch hier vom Herrn
sablattnik noch einmal nachgefragt
worden ist dass Jahresbudget sind 2,7
Milliarden Euro für das heurige Jahr ab
dem nächsten Jahr folgen 680 Millionen
Euro dazu zum Jahresbudget das
entspricht nach der Berechnung nach der
Berechnung
um international auch vergleichbar zu
sein dem einen Prozent des BIP was viel
wichtiger ist noch ist dass wir diese
Pfad bereits früher erreichen das heißt
wir sind ab
2027 bei 1,5 Prozent und wenn Sie
ansprechen dass da jemand das da
Enttäuschung herrscht dann würde ich
noch auf etwas verweisen es hat einen
sehr umfangreichen Bericht gegeben unser
Herr hat sich der genannt ein sehr
dickes Buch was notwendig ist und wie
viel an finanziellen Mitteln auch
notwendig ist um das österreichische
Bundesheer für die Zukunft auch zu
rüsten wenn sie sich diese Kurve
anschauen und die mit dem jetzigen
Budgetpfad vergleichen dann wissen Sie
wovon ich rede
nachdem es jetzt keine weiteren Fragen
gibt
bedanke ich mich recht herzlich für
erscheinen und auf die heutige
Pressekonferenz für beendet erklären
danke sehr dankeschön